l'informatique est donc une discipline
scientifique que l'on peut apprendre
tout en s'amusant qu'en soient petits ou
grands de 7 à 107 ans avec un ordinateur
ou sans donc là vous êtes assez contents
que je sois chercheuse en informatique
et pas poétesse vous vous doutez que je
vais pas briguer un prix nobel de
littérature avec des vers de mirliton
comme ça quand on m'a invité à venir
parler ici de less is best
j'étais un peu embêté parce que pour moi
more is best plus de compréhension plus
de connaissances sur l'informatique ça
me paraît essentiel alors comme je suis
une élève sage j'essaie de me plier à
l'exercice
j'ai me laissent ignorance is best et ça
m'a fait penser à une citation d'un
ancien président de ravoir d'university
derek boxe si j'oublie pas son nom qui
disait si vous trouvez que l'éducation
coûte cher essayez le prix de
l'ignorance alors pourquoi apprendre
l'informatique à l'informatique est
partout dans notre monde et donc c'est
important de connaître d'être éclairé
sur ce qui nous entoure
donc évidemment l'informatique elle se
trouve dans nos ordinateurs
elle se trouve aussi dans nos téléphones
qui servent que accessoirement à
téléphoner le miam sert à courir par
exemple enregistrer mes courses
on le trouve également dans nos gps qui
détermine nos positions en communiquant
avec des satellites qui nous calcule le
meilleur chemin pour aller à un endroit
précis on peut les trouver dans votre
vie quotidienne dans nos systèmes de
chauffage qui peuvent envoyer des
informations à nos fameux téléphone etc
où notre réfrigérateur qui pourrait nous
indiquer qu'il est temps d'aller acheter
des yaourts si on est plus pour en
trouver dans nos appareils photo qui
améliore beaucoup les photos qu'on peut
prendre en mettant au point en réglant
la lumière on peut en trouver dans la
grille ce qui est derrière moi c'est la
google car
donc elle conduira bientôt à notre place
peut-être dans les robots domestiques
qui permettent aux personnes âgées de
rester à la maison
dans notre vie sociale en à facebook etc
l'informatique est partout on voit
qu'elle est pas uniquement dans nos
ordinateurs est donc une des premières
choses que je vais vous montrer c'est
que il important d'apprendre
l'informatique mais l'informatique n'est
pas la science des ordinateurs pas plus
que l'astronomie ne sera la science des
télescopes
certains peuvent dire que ça sert à rien
d'apprendre l'informer
tic puisque on n'a pas besoin
d'apprendre la mécanique pour conduire
une voiture le fait que l'informatique
ne soit pas la science des ordinateurs
ça peut expliquer pourquoi il est
important de comprendre l'informatique
parce que ce n'est pas uniquement la
science des ordinateurs c'est une
science qui nous qui sert de béquilles
un autre pan c'est donc michel serres
par exemple dit que tout comme
l'écriture a permis de libérer notre
mémoire un tas de choses puisque elles
sont écrites
peut-être que l'informatique va
permettre de libérer notre cerveau un
tas de tâches
il nous reste à voir ce qu'il va pouvoir
inventer avec sur la discussion sur
l'informatique
on a aussi des gens qui ont dit il ya
une dizaine d'années janet ring par
exemple mais c'est un mouvement qui est
plus ancien que l'informatique c'est
important à prendre parce qu'il ya une
pensée informatique
une pensée qui consiste à quand on veut
résoudre un problème analysé pas par
étape par étape les ce qui permet de
résoudre le problème de passer dans
l'abstraction de d'utiliser des
mathématiques de regarder à quel point
c'est difficile ou pas de résoudre le
problème
et puis peter d'énigmes en mai 2009 lui
a répondu que c'est un peu dangereux
comme caractérisation de l'informatique
parce que la pensée informatique tel
quel la définissait la pensée
computational stinking telle qu'elle l'a
défini c est pas spécifique à
l'informatique toutes les sciences
peuvent se l'approprier et donc peter
denning dit attention à l'informatique
c'est bien une séance spécifique qui est
la science des propriétés du traitement
de l'information
donc je reviens sur ce point
l'informatique n'est pas la science des
ordinateurs et j'ai eu envie d'aller
enseigner l'informatique tout simplement
dans l'école de mes enfants de
construire un petit curriculum
d'informatique pour des cm1 cm2 ce
curriculum gelé basée sur le programme
d'informatique qui est enseigné au lycée
et puisque l'informatique n'est pas la
science des ordinateurs j'ai commencé à
faire de l'informatique sans ordinateur
alors c'est pas une idée à moi
l'informatique débrancher c'est ça a été
inventé en particulier par tim bale qui
est néo zélandais et puis vous avez un
site qui est des vous qui s'appelle
computer signs and played donc
informatique débrancher un français anne
plug c'est plus rigolo en anglais parce
que ça fait référence au concert
acoustique à la grande époque des
concerts électriques électroniques et
donc on a fait de l'informatique sans
ordinateur ça n'a posé aucun problème
aux enfants
2faire l'informatique sans ordinateur
donc on a commencé par deux des quatre
volets que je voulais regarder un
premier volet c'était des algorithmes
donc on a joué au jeu denis par exemple
je de nîmes c'est un jeu où il ya une
stratégie gagnante
donc c'est plus un jeu il faut trouver
l'algorithme qui permet de gagner on a
joué aussi au crêpier psychorigide donc
le crêpier veut ranger sa boutique le
soir avant de fermer et il veut que ce
soit bien rangé il veut que tout ces
crêpes soit par piles de taille
décroissante des belle pyramide est le
seul mouvement qui est possible c'est
qui glisse sa spatule entre deux crêpes
et qui retournent tous qui en dessus et
donc on a distribué des petites crêpes
en bois aux enfants et on leur a demandé
de regarder de chercher comment faire
pour ranger ses piles ils ont fini par
trouver l'algorithme c'est un algorithme
qui est un algorithme récursif donc en
général c'est un album c'est un type
d'algorithmes qui est difficile à saisir
et à comprendre même pour les étudiants
de première deuxième année à
l'université et là à 9 ans et sont
débrouillés avec leurs algorithmes
récursif ils ont rangé leurs crêpes
j'ai vraiment essayé d'insister sur les
aspects manipulation et sur le fait
d'engager son corps dans ce qu'on
faisait donc on a même fait des
algorithmes de tri où les enfants
avaient des petits cartons avec des
nombres à trié par exemple du plus petit
au plus grand et se déplacer au sol sur
un réseau donc on a vu des algorithmes
parallèle alors c'est pas tout à fait la
photo qui est là mais presque
et puis dans le deuxième volet en effet
du codage binaire alors là certains
m'ont dit tu voles le codage binaire
c'est extrêmement abstrait et pas du
tout monde à coder en binaire des images
noir et blanc on a codé en binaire
dénombre en à coder en binaire
l'alphabet est le point de départ le
fait qu'ils les accrocher le fait qu'ils
avaient envie de savoir comment ça
marche et c'est qu'on faisait des tours
de magie
alors le petit dessein de danse que vous
voyez à la fin en effet un truc tout à
la fin les en à coder l'alphabet en
binaire chaque enfant à cause d un petit
message en un mot de 4,5 lettres et puis
on a dansé 1 0 1 1 0 et c est les autres
enfants devaient décoller donc il est
même possible de danser du codage
binaire alors en passant au cm2 cette
fois ci je me suis dit qu'on allait
peut-être utilisé un peu de matériel au
moins électronique voire informatique
donc on a commencé par utiliser des
robots donc les enfants ont fait les
robots
même dans la cour c'était la photo qui
avait tout au début et puis ensuite ils
ont programmé des robots pour que les
robots face ce qu'on leur ce qu'on
voulait qu'ils fassent donc ils ont
compris ce que ça voulait dire dire aux
robots de suivre une ligne au sol par
exemple
et puis pour savoir ce qu'il a dans un
ordinateur pour beaucoup de gens
peut-être que pour vous aussi si je vous
demande ce qui est dans un ordinateur
vous aurez des mots vous aurez carte
mère processeur disque dur il serait pas
trop ce que c'est bon on a ouvert un
ordinateur on doit regarder
voilà et puis tout à la fin je suis
passé au dernier volet à ce que tout le
monde confond avec l'informatique tout à
la fin on est passé à la programmation
donc j'ai utilisé un logiciel qui est
développé par la myhtique s'appelle
scratch ou c'est très visuel
donc on a des blocs qui sont comme des
gueules de crocodiles par exemple ici
vous avez répéter indéfiniment le même
la même séquence d'action et puis de
dans la gueule du crocodile vous pouvez
les fours et tout ce que vous voulez que
le crocodile fasse autant de fois que
vous voulez et pour le moment on est en
train de on est parti pour faire un
petit court métrage donc l'image que
vous aviez tout au début avec les
lettres de mon prénom c'est le générique
de mon petit court métrage c'est les
lettres de mon prénom qui arrive qui
s'assemblent correctement alors comment
faire si vous n'êtes pas élèves dans
cette école de cm2 de 2 cm 1 de cm2 je
vous parlais d'un projet en cours qui
est destiné à tout le monde donc ce
projet est mené avec la maison des
mathématiques et de l'informatique qui
est en lieu à lyon qui est destiné à
diffuser les sciences informatiques et
mathématiques à tout public
donc on accueille évidemment beaucoup de
scolaires pendant les périodes scolaires
des périscolaires
mais le samedi le vendre le mercredi
après midi le samedi après midi
c'est entrée libre et gratuite à tout
public et l'année prochaine on aura un
thème sur la magie et donc j'ai un
certain nombre de tours de magie qui me
permet d expliquer certains concept
d'informatique comme le codage binaire à
nouveau les algorithmes où les graphes
les graphes on pourrait dire que les
graves sont informaticiens et
informaticiennes ce que les équations
sont mathématicien mathématicienne c'est
un outil de la boîte à outils voilà pour
terminer j'espère vous avoir convaincus
qu'il important d'étudier l'informatique
comme une science
et qu'il est possible de s'y mettre de
la façon qui nous convient le mieux à
tout âge et je vais emprunter ma
conclusion à marie l'huissier qui ne
doctorante en deuxième année en
mathématiques l'école normale supérieure
de lyon donc très souvent quand on
étudie l'informatique ou les sciences
c'est parce qu'on va en faire son métier
qui si on est l insa et les étudiants de
ginza veulent en faire leur métier et on
aimerait bien qu'ils se passe autre
chose si on regarde les pratiques
artistiques
on peut apprendre à jouer d'un
instrument de musique par exemple à
n'importe quel âge et pas dans
l'objectif d'aller faire des tournées
internationales
juste pour se faire plaisir pour le
sport c'est pareil on peut se mettre au
sport à n'importe quel âge au fait si
bien son sport et l'objectif c'est pas
de devenir champion aux championnes
olympiques
l'objectif c'est de se faire plaisir
j'aimerais que pour l'informatique et
les sciences de façon plus générale on
puisse également se mettre à faire à
apprendre ces sciences pas
nécessairement pour en faire son métier
mais par plaisir